hi there I've recently been interviewed
by the YouTube channel Henry AI Labs by
Connor shorten and what follows is the
resulting conversation we had about
population based methods and open-ended
learning things like that basically
topics of the ICML tutorial that we both
saw it's important to note that none of
us is really an expert on the topic but
we are trying to make sense of it and I
mean like just kind of talking about the
ideas so please enjoy the conversation
with corner shorten definitely check out
the Henry AI Labs channel and yeah have
a good time thanks for watching the
Henry Aird labs deep learning podcast
today I'm joined with Jana Kilcher
Yannick is works in the data analytics
lab at ETH he has a great YouTube
channel I really enjoy watching his
paper summary videos if you like any of
the videos that I'm making you've
definitely also like checking out this
channel I'm gonna put the link in
description at the end of the talk
Yannick thanks for doing this than they
ever let appreciate it thanks for having
me that's cool yeah so what we're gonna
talk about is population-based search
and presentation that I see though that
I really thought was interesting about
emphasizing diversity and novelty in
search so the first question I just
wanted to start by generally talking
about your opinion on population based
search and the differences between
population based search and like
gradient descent going straight for one
solution yes so the the kind of main
difference is that in population based
search as the name implies you maintain
kind of a large population of solutions
so you don't want to limit yourself to
just one trajectory say I start here and
then I run towards my goal but you kind
of maintain a lot of hypotheses of what
the solution could be and then you kinda
want to update all of them at the same
time and so there's many different
variants of population based search but
they all have this this thing in common
where you maintain many solutions
you can't have bet on one of them
becoming a good one basically yes so one
of the thing they they present their
paper where they have the robot walking
and if it breaks one of his legs for
example it can go back to the map of
Leeds table and and say okay well I lost
this leg but I think maybe this solution
I was I wasn't too clear on how that
would really be related so maybe
wondering if you had a more insight on
that yes so the so the maybe the the
context is yeah you want to teach a
robot to walk and the robot had six legs
I believe so and if you think of what's
the solution to the problem a solution
is kind of an algorithm that takes the
current sensor input and outputs how to
move the motors right so and if you just
have flexing your gradient descent
algorithm converging on the best
solution of how to move the robot it's
just going to be like oh these are the
sensors okay I'm going to move like this
like this like this like this but if one
leg breaks of course you're lost because
you only know this one way of moving and
now the sorry so you only know this one
way of moving basically and that's it
but in population based search if you
think of the solution as a way to move
you maintain many many ways to move so
you basically the objective if you can
call it like this is algorithm find me a
lot of different ways to move right with
my six legs and now if one of my legs I
still can evaluate all of them I still
can find okay which one's the best but
if not one of them falls away I have all
these other solutions that I can try
right so then what they would do is like
this light falls wait now they just
re-evaluate all of those solutions while
only having five legs and the best of
those like is much more likely to kind
of work then if you had just your single
solution so that kind of
that's the it's population-based because
you maintain many different ways of
solving the problem yes I was thinking
about like using the search algorithms
that control neural architecture search
and things like that so it's trying to
think of how you might extend these
ideas from the robot walking with six
legs to the RN and controller designing
the convolutional network but like maybe
I might have like more of them storage
constraint or more of a latency
constraint and I could jump to a
different solution like that just
wondering how you think like these ideas
of population-based search translate
into the neural architecture search and
specifically if it really is important
because like you've got I feel like in
neural architecture search you have such
a direct signal with the classification
accuracy like I don't see as much
variance as it was in the in the
objective function yeah I really think
this population based approach is they
shine in so they shine in multiple
different areas but one area where they
shine is definitely when the environment
changes so when you know something about
whatever your input changes like the
robot losing a leg so in kind of neural
architecture search you might you might
find these methods working if you then
go for let's say transfer learning so
you kinda train your network on one task
you want to actually do it in another
task right and then if you maintain many
solutions and you can evaluate all of
them getting it in this transfer setting
it's much more likely that one of them
you know it's gonna be is gonna be fine
so but you're right of I also believe
that directly in architecture search
maybe it's not maybe it doesn't yield
that many great results though the other
of course the other area where these
methods shine and this is with respect
to algorithms like novelty search which
can be implemented as a population based
method is
they gave this really good example of
deception in a search problem so a
deception would be like if you have a
robot walking a maze and the robot just
wants to get to the goal right and you
would program it the robot to be
rewarded the closer it gets to the goal
but if like there's a wall in between
and you actually need to go around the
wall kind of then for a while you will
need to move away from the goal in order
to reach it so if you have like a pure
objective driven approach you just go
straight to the the goal you would
always get stuck at the wall but if you
then kind of do what is called a novelty
search where he basically reward the
robot for things it has never done
before it would actually find its way
around the wall so you can maintain
population of solutions that all kind of
explore the space and that in neuro
architecture search maybe it's of a
benefit that actually you know if I I
probably always benefit from like adding
more layers or neurons or something like
this but maybe I actually want to prune
some stuff first and then add some more
stuff so maybe want to get worse first
before I can get even better
right so mmm so is it reached where I
can imagine happening but I don't know
yeah there's think in the changing
environment I definitely think like when
you deploy a model and then you're
getting new data that you could frame
that as a changing environment and then
also thinking about like in the context
of Gans which is something that I think
is really interesting that the
discriminator classifying the Gans and
the generator samples it's a changing
environment because of the generators
updates so maybe having some kind of
population-based can our discriminator
model might help it avoid that like
continual learning problem I guess is
sort of it yeah that could that might as
might very well be there are approaches
to Gans I believe where you based you
have like many discriminators and each
one kind of only has let's say has its
own limited view on the day turn you're
trying to kind of fool a lot of them at
the same time but it's not the same
thing but yes
I think that I'm yeah I've seen that
multiple generator multiple
discriminator model two I think that's
really interesting as well so then one
other thing I was curious about is this
idea of goal switching and how that
might relate to the like Otto Amell on
our existing somewhere like heavily
studied things like classification
localization semantic segmentation like
how do you think goal switching could be
important like one idea I had is maybe
if you've got like multi-class
classification and it's got like a
really low false positive rate or
something on like one class you might
say well you've somehow learned a
decision boundary on that class or do
you think that wouldn't generalize and
that there's no sense and goal switching
in like a multi-class classification
problem so yep in general well when you
think of goal switching in general how
they introduced it was also in the
context of like this population based
search of these map elites maybe it's
kind of so what map elites the algorithm
does basically is it says okay I have a
number of dimensions that I could solve
the problem on and they introduced okay
let's take life on Earth needs to
whatever survive so I can either be like
a super tall creature right to reach
fruit that no one else can reach I can
be a super fast creature right to kind
of run away from everything or it can be
a super heavy creature so that no one
can attack me and so these are kind of
the dimensions that you can solve the
problem of reproduction and survival and
within so that what map elites does it
it will segment this area so let's say
size and speed it would segment this
into a grid and in each grid it would
kind of maintain the best solution so
far that is within that grid and then
what they see is when they then kind of
evolve this over time and improve each
each grid is that inventions let's say
inventions algorithm discoveries in one
grid say for a very fast creature they
would then kind of be adapted to
the very let's say a very heavy creature
so like fast creature kind of discovers
or longer legs make me even faster maybe
the longer legs came in and we combined
in the heavy creature to do something
else that this kind of goal switching
it's think of like feathers being first
kind of developed or evolved for warmth
for temperature regulation then being
goal switched over to adapt it for
flight so in the in terms of multi-class
classification i guess it's a bit of a
different problem if you just have one
classifier you can definitely make the
argument that since you know you're
learning maybe to classify one class
really well a low false positive rate
you have learned very good features for
that class and if some other class kind
of like the zebra is a worse with
stripes and then the horse is a horse
but with the feature stripes being
really low you can probably classify
that better something making stuff up
here but it's a bit of a different
context i I feel the if you have a
single classifier do multi-class
classification but definitely the logic
applies in the feature space I would say
where you learn features for one class
and they might become useful for another
class yeah have this other thoughts when
you're discussing eyes like we've got
like a multi class multitask learning
like maybe my intermediate feature is
getting mapped to a classifier I get
mapped to a segmentation get mapped to
again like good goal switching improve
multitask learning yeah I would
definitely say so I think that that's
exactly what we're seeing when you look
at for example pre-training so if you
think of like this these newest big
language models like burt or something
they're really good at tasks I don't
know I don't know what it was an NLP
task
labeling of sentiment sentiment
classification because
it's so easy but let's say Birds is
really good at sentiment classification
but if you were just to Train it
outright on sentiment classification
it's probably not gonna work because
there's just too little signal but then
what happens is you pre-trained it as a
language model as this mask language
model and it kind of gets really good at
simply comprehending a language and that
skill can then be kind of adapted over
into the into the Samantha
sorry into the sentiment classification
realm so I I think if you look at yep
something like retraining or multitask
as you say then definitely one tap want
the addition of a task might give rise
to certain features that then all of a
sudden can be adapted by another task
whereas if you just trained the latter
task by itself that maybe would have
been too difficult so yeah definitely in
an analogy so then what I think about is
so I'm going from my pre trained and
language model into sentiment
classification and maybe I also add like
question answer during document
summarization named entity like this
like a vector of tasks that it can go do
I'm then curious like when your goal
switching it's like how do you then
combine the features later on or you
just like take it as if I need this task
I'll go to this model like yeah well the
question here is to you whether or not
you implement this as a single model and
kind of refer to the goal switching of
features within that model or whether
you also do this now as a population
based method where basically you
maintain you you maintain different
neural networks for different
combination of these tasks then you'd
actually need a method to kind of
combine and reproduce the neural
networks themselves which I yeah I I see
that's it's gonna be a bit of a
different ask like some cross
distillation or some something crazy
yeah I don't know how that would work
exactly yeah I just wonder about two
things it's like do
population-based search could you have
like the weights be the population like
different sets of weights or would it
necessarily need to be like taking apart
the layers and designing new internal
like cells in the architecture search
like because if I just have the weights
maybe I could treat the diversity search
or goal switching as like stochastic
weight averaging and just like mesh them
all together when I'm finished with my
goal switching at the end but if it's
yeah if I definitely be if you wanted to
if you yeah if you wanted to if you
wanted to implement your multitask
multitask tasking as a population based
approach where yeah you could def it
would definitely give you an easier time
if you keep the architecture of your
neural networks the same and simply have
different weights and then you could
indeed consider something like weight
averaging or or yeah I guess a more
modern approach would be like
distillation from it the two teacher
models into one child mode it's actually
a good metaphor for a for reproduction
kind of a distillation from multiple
teacher model I don't know if anyone's
done that yet but yeah I guess that
might be the way to do it if you also
maintain different architectures for
different problems that might be a bit
of a yeah that's an interesting thing
too you have the total switching and
then you model distill it all into one
model that is yes well if you think of
math elites right it simply you simply
distill it into the appropriate I don't
even know what the what the axis would
be probably I can imagine okay
you have like three tasks so you have
three axes and then you'd mix the tasks
maybe in accordance on how far up your
of these axes you are or something like
this it's not exactly math elites
because your actual objectives are on
the axis but
and I don't know yes but just to
backtrack one step I want to talk about
like diversity centric search novelty
you like when I was thinking about that
I was like can't you just initialize as
it's it such that it has maximum
diversity like can't you just initialize
the population such that they're all
like uniformly spaced and then search
locally from there I so I just wonder
what you think on that and how this is
different from that so yeah and these in
these diversity search algorithms
basically what you're you're doing is
you're your only goal is or your main
goal depends on Yavin
but let's say your only goal is to find
diverse behaviors or diverse solutions
diverse I think the main problem with
that is is that the search space is so
extremely large that you're gonna have a
hard time even even defining what a kind
of a uniform distribution is because
it's such a high dimensional space that
even if you sample uniformly it it's
it's almost empty like we're almost
right you're not you're not getting
anywhere because you have finite finite
computer you need to implement an
algorithm even if you even if unless
computer can hold a hundred thousand
different members of a population in
high dimensions that is nothing right so
to me yet the initialization might be
definitely important but I don't think
you you get around some sort of
iterative procedure and carry them
around weeding out weeding out things
such that you have space for interesting
things because ultimately what you want
to find is something interesting in the
robot maze example the novelty search
basically is here is a robot you started
right and then you want to do something
that you haven't done yet
right so if the robots crashes into a
wall the first time that's a good thing
you say are cool you haven't done that
yet but if it crashes into the wall the
second time you're like you've done that
already right so you you you basically
need a measure of saying how close to
behaviors are but if the robot has
crashed into every wall once the only
thing it can do if it wants to do
something new is actually go around the
wall and then you're like oh cool you've
done something new but the space of
behaviors often is so large that you
can't simply enumerate all the all the
behaviors so you I think that's the the
main problem why you can't just make it
diverse from the beginning yeah when I
was thinking about that I thinking that
maybe the like reward function if you're
like navigating the maze it needs to be
more refined so I give it crashes into
the wall that needs to be like I don't
know plus 3u something some like unique
signal I feel like in order to create
that kind of because I get thinking you
know if it's just like rewards zero
everywhere but one if you hit that a
finish line and then maybe some kind of
like discounting for how long it takes
you to get there it's like I don't see
how it could interpret that it's done a
new behavior if all it has is it so that
so to me it feels like it's all about
the design of the reward space now
implementing such a thing yes absolutely
so the that the definitely if you wanted
to do novelty search you would need to
implement a measure of how close to
behaviors are so there's no way around
and I think that's kind of crux of the
of this method is that by specifying how
close to behaviors are so what what
constitutes novelty and what doesn't you
already implicitly kind of telling the
robot something about the nature of of
the world so I think that the kind of
the objective because they now say oh we
don't give the robot the objecting of
reaching the target we simply give it
the objective of not doing the same
thing twice I think the the kind of
objective sneaks in in like a
through the specification of half of you
how close are two behaviors but
definitely this is just kind of a really
simple example what they want to say is
that these methods really become
important when you have ambitious
objectives right in the maze we can all
agree if we just design the reward
crashing wall is bad you don't have to
actually go straight to the goal you can
you know but go around walls good and so
on then it's easy right but in really
ambitious objectives like no flying
reaching the moon in the in the 1960s
designing general AI curing cancer and
so on we don't actually know how to
design the reward right because we don't
know which steps need to be fulfilled in
order to to fly to the moon
I guess now we do in hindsight right but
we you couldn't have predicted we don't
know which steps need to be discovered
in order to cure cancer and it's very
very probable if you look at history
that the fundamental discoveries that
lead to us curing cancer will not
directly come from cancer research
that's that's their entire point right
it's not like you can have a goal go
straight towards it if it's like a
really ambitious goal very probably the
solutions will come in part from
extremely non related fields and they
and you kind of have to make advances
everywhere and in order to solve that
problem so the the question of it's all
desire it's all designed to reward yes
but we would have to know how the reward
must be must look and in these really
ambitious objectives we don't and that's
that's where they argue we well the best
thing actually you can do is to just
explore and you just find interesting
things along the way and you kind of
hope these interesting things will come
no you know the interesting things will
combine to form new interesting things
right
but you just don't know where you're
gonna end up right yes I guess maybe you
could just keep a trip like the
trajectory of States and use that as
your signal novelty but then I think
like if you've got like a robotic arm
with like X degrees of freedom it's like
the state space this would be to
infinite to really like say oh this is
significantly this is a significantly
different sequential procedure of states
and this other thing so then the next
thing yes I think this is a good
transition into their pick breeder
experiment and so anyone who listens to
this who hasn't watched their top the
pig breeder is like they've got these
generator neural networks with sets of
weights and they have like humans go on
and they pick two of the generated
images to blend together and derive a
new image and so this repeats on and on
and so it goes from like just like a
spiral pattern into like a skull face
drawing or a butterfly drawing or
something like that and they so this
idea is supposed to represent
open-endedness in an environment and uh
so it just generally I I just found it
to be really interesting I think it's
one of the things in their talk that you
look at it and you're like oh that's
interesting what what is going on here
but it's like the the mutation is really
guided by the human search which is so
complex I feel like this is wondering
what you thought of that pig breeder
experiment II yeah it's really cool and
it's it's it's actually the basis for
their entire books I've read the the
book the UM my greatness cannot be
planned I believe I've got the title so
that this they actually they kind of
start out with this as a motivational
example of what if what if the only goal
is to do something interesting and
without any objective so all you do is
kind of choose slight variations on a
current picture
and you see what you end up with and I
thought I thought it Allah straights
their point it's extremely well so it
illustrates for example goal switching
is that so if you were done with your
sequence of image manipulations you
could then save it into the database and
someone else could pick up from it and
then kind of continue it and since every
human finds slightly different things
interesting right you could take someone
else's final result and say uh you know
that that kinda looks weird but then you
your modifications to it will be
different than had that human continued
breeding the picture so what you you end
up is and they show this for example one
picture ends up being a car and it had
been adapted from an alien face where
the eyes of the alien face became the
wheels of the car and so the first the
first person might have been like oh
this this this looks more and more like
an alien face I'm gonna you know make it
more like an alien face and then the
second person is like other kind of
looks nice I'm gonna modify it in a
different so they they basically it
basically give this example of if you
have an ambitious goal like getting to a
car just from these very simple picture
generation networks then the stepping
stones to get there have nothing to do
with cars and the people that did it
didn't have a car in mind while going
there and the second thing is that if
you try to get a car from the beginning
I believe if they write they've done
this if you try to keep you can't like
it's just the sequence of things that
you have to go through is so complicated
and convoluted if you were to try to end
up with a result it's it's basically
impossible so these kind of illustrate
their points very very nicely and I mean
it's a cool experiment in itself but
they use it kind of as a basis metaphor
for then going on jumping off yeah
think it's so interesting this idea that
it's like you can't design a car unless
unless you don't try it unless you just
happen to come across that it's sort of
like I think about like if I was to fire
up GarageBand and start trying to make a
song it's like I don't know exactly what
it's gonna sound like I'm just gonna
kind of explore until I come across
something so then I was thinking about
left like with the Gans and the way that
the Gans design images like so this is
like sort of a design I drew up that I'm
curious what you think of its like what
if the generator just like tries to make
some object and then a preaching
classifier says oh I think it looks like
this maybe and then you send it to like
a refining network so the Gann just sort
of searches for objects and then some
classifiers like I think it looks like
sort of like how the pig breeder sort of
like how we're like oh I think this
looks like a skull or whatever so I'm
gonna try to you know refine it now do
you think that would be an interesting
thing or you'd have like a two-stage
process first to do something general
and then it gets classified and then
you'd have like a special generator just
for the skull class and the special
discriminator just for that yeah I don't
see why not
but I'd be heart it might be hard to get
the first generator to to be
sufficiently diverse so you might might
need some kind of discriminator signal
at the even at the beginning you're like
how do you think the pig breeder
experiment could be fully automated such
that there's no human in the loop yeah
that's that's a thought I had as well
because it to me it seems that the the
kind of of course the resulting pictures
the fact that they look like human
objects or recognizable object is it a
result from them being being bred by
humans like the fact that it looks like
a car or a skull or something like this
is it's very much but also I guess that
that could be abstracted in we just not
expect the results to be like human
recognizable objects
but maybe something else like the much
more deeper construction in pig breeder
is the fact that the measure of
interestingness is provided by the
humans right so the humans say they
click on a picture and then they get
variants of the picture and they click
on the one that they most like this this
sense of interestingness of I like this
one this that's what's that's the
fundamental core that's provided by the
humans as an input to the system that's
what drives the entire thing that's
exactly the same as before
it's when you write when you teach the
robot which two behaviors are close
enough like oh no that's too close to
before that's not novel or yes that's
sufficiently different than before that
is novel right this the sense is somehow
you either need to specify it or you
need to have a human in the loop to
provide it and I feel it's very very
hard to capture that in an algorithm as
as of today you know like something I
think about is like maybe I'd have like
my a thousand class imagenet classifier
and then maybe I'd have like like a
style classifier like a neural style
transfer network that I've liked chopped
off the like some intermediate feature
I'm gonna take that as my style and so
maybe I'm like classifying I think it's
like an airplane and then I kind of like
this style for it that's sort of like my
like how I would think about trying to
automate that like I don't know I guess
like I don't know if I I guess it's
interesting but I also feel like when
you're doing the pig breeder you're kind
of like oh I'm gonna try it now and now
that I see this vision I'm gonna try to
make it like look like that now I
suppose like that yeah yeah I think yeah
yeah I got a good name this into a
school and then you start doing yes yeah
yes they're very much so they're not
they're not advocating random
exploration what they're advocating is
basically if you have an ambitious goal
then you basically don't know the
stepping stones
but from stepping stone to stepping
stone
that's where objectives are very handy
so when you want to say I this already
kinda looks like something I want to
make it more like that I wanna make it
more into a scholar it already has like
two circles and kind of the shape but
I'm going to drive it there that that is
very that can be very objective driven
but in the grand scheme of things you
don't know then once you have the skull
right someone else can develop that into
an even new thing so yeah indeed if if
you if you're in kind of a local search
in this space then an objective driven
you really like what you're saying like
I want to make it as much this as
possible that's very that's actually the
thing they're advocating for but then
from there end result yeah you would
need to then restart again do the same
thing with like something else yeah
interesting I just thinking about
yeah and think about like the stepping
stones and like is how would you define
the space of stepping stones to such a
to any kind of thing I guess it's like
you could still design some kind of
maybe it's discrete or maybe you have
some kind of signal you can get back
from it and I guess it's just a lot to
think about
uh-huh they give this they give this
great analogy I feel like if you have a
really ambitious objective it's like
crossing a lake but the lake is covered
in fog so you basically can't really see
very far but you can always kind of see
the next stepping stones right and you
can then you can then try to go from
stepping stone to stepping stone but you
don't know which one to take if there's
like a fork and there's two ways pause
you don't know which one right so all
you can do is basically go the most
interesting one and they relate this to
scientific research so yeah if we want
to accomplish some really great research
goal like artificial general
intelligence we don't like we don't know
but we can see the next stepping stones
right we can see Oh from what we have
right now what interesting combination
could we make that's still kinda it
still kind of makes that's not total
garbage
right so in in the local search I can
try to say I want to I don't know I want
to do this I want to do multiple
generators and it's multistage and then
this thing right just this is kind of a
stepping stone and maybe that will then
lead to something more interesting and
so on so yeah that's that's kind of how
they relate I like this metaphor of the
lake yeah yeah is like good like a meta
controller or try to put the stones down
and then the objective or is the space
too enormous that that idea of having a
better controller guide the stepping
stone placement is just like absurdum it
and there's no way that that would work
that's sort of where I'm thinking with
this Nozick so they actually that's
that's exactly the the question right of
what I so I believe you need such a
matter whatever
because the space is too large you
somehow need a way to choose the
stepping stones in the first place right
you somehow need a way to do this now
what they're saying is that if you're if
your goal is really ambitious then a
meta controller that simply wants to
reach the goal is bad because right
because what we discussed before you
might need a lot of inventions from
other fields in order to make gold
happen and if you simply go your field
maximum power towards your goal that's
not gonna happen now if your meta
controller is actually just something
that wants to produce interesting things
then that's actually something they they
advocate for that is exactly what their
algorithms are trying to capture they're
trying to capture locally yeah we want
to get better at a particular thing what
those particular things are and the
order of these that should be novelty
driven instead of gold ribbon yeah yeah
yeah the interesting component and I
guess I'm sort of biased towards liking
the objective design and now I'm
thinking like okay well let's abstract
those Medic controllers one level up and
have a meta meta controller and just
repeat this and share hierarchy makes
sense and that if you if you if you're
if you're a bit cynical that is what you
will also hear out of here out of and
they have to argue in the in their book
a lot of guests that like isn't the
question isn't the kind of isn't the
implementation of a meta controller that
just searches for novelty in itself an
objective again and then they give some
good reasons why actually you don't you
it is different it's more like a
constraint on your search if you think
of natural evolution for example it
isn't really doesn't really have an
objective and and if you think
reproduction and survival is the
objective of natural evolution it it
doesn't really
good the good reason they give is the
objective has already been fulfilled by
the very first organism to ever live
right why didn't it stop there why
didn't it stop very first cell okay done
we fulfil it's more of a it's more of an
actually a constrained optimization
where the constraint is you need to be
able to survive that's kind of the
minimum bar of to being on this planet
and then what I'm saying constrained
optimization but it's it's not it's not
an optimization it's more of like a
constraint constraint search I think
yeah I guess it's like I don't think I'm
closed in this world of trying to think
of these construction problems and I
haven't really like thought more
generally about just like exploration as
a whole but but anyway so I just wanted
to ask you generally like your deep
learning research I would ask like what
areas of deep learning are you really
interested in right now and what do you
think is promising in the near future so
I'm currently working in adversarial
examples that is a really interesting
topic there's lots of questions still
still open but I'm generally interested
in pretty much any anything that is not
I'm not too interested in like the
newest the newest fine technique on
getting the latest state-of-the-art
numbers even though that's probably
super important for practitioners
basically agreeing more with the authors
of this tutorial of that let's just try
to do interesting things and to me these
actually these are these areas in in
terms of open-ended open-ended search
open-ended learning are very interesting
I think reinforcement learning still has
a long way to go I think actually NLP
still has a long way to go because I
don't believe it's the current models
are at the end of it
so I think it's a really exciting time
yeah although think about adversary
examples because it definitely flips the
CNN idea on its head and in the night so
I had one other thing about adversarial
examples that I'm interested in is uh
there is like an interview with Elon
Musk and this Lex Friedman research
where he asks in about adversarial
examples on his self-driving cars and he
seems dismissive of it he says he thinks
basically you could just average
different patches with like test time
augmentation to overcome adversarial
examples so in your research do you
think that like the example where they
add the noise masks to the Panda and
they're like oh that's a given now if
they just perturb it like nine more
times do you think the prediction would
average out to pandas still
that is a that is a very difficult
question and in from experience simply
adding noise and then feeding it to the
classifier even if you average after
that usually will it will defend against
adversarial examples to a point but it
will also degrade your your
classification performance because so
maybe I understood it wrong but my
understanding is I have my input right
and I simply add noise to it and then
feed it through the network and I could
do this many times right in an average
the prediction but usually this will
help against adversarial examples but it
will also also degrade the accuracy of
that classifier so it might actually
make your self-driving car worse in the
in the overall because how often is it
gonna be attack against a adversarial
example like it's gonna be attacked
maybe I don't know once or twice a year
maybe if drives by some some hackers
house writes a big sticker on a stop
sign or something but the rest of the
time I would actually like to retain
retain the best possible classifier and
if I always have to add noise then that
that's not possible so that the research
we're doing is actually into the
direction of can we retain the original
accuracy while still kind of detecting
these these samples it's I mean it's you
somehow have to get a trade off
somewhere but just adding noise isn't D
isn't the final solution yet I was like
so with these adversarial examples
they're only gonna make
misclassifications like that if it
really is adversarially sought after
it's not just like the noise
perturbation would be such an enormous
base to find it otherwise
so yes you really need to try so it was
very unlikely that that some random
thing of course these networks can be
confused by random noise but I think one
of the self-driving cars once drove into
a big white truck because it was large
white so it thought it was sky but her
other like like other than these
failures yeah you really have to try to
find an adversarial example really cool
a Yannick thanks so much for doing this
anybody won't watch even listening
definitely check out Yannick YouTube
channel he has really great paper
summaries and all sorts of things thank
you hey thanks so much for having me